uh more on our top story the government
defending its 1.4 billion
programme to help children across
england catch up on lost
learning caused by the pandemic let's
speak to the shadow education secretary
kate green good morning to you i mean
the education
secretary tells us this is the beginning
of a true revolution
it's a very slow revolution it's um a
revolution that falls
woefully inadequate of what the
government's own education experts or
kevin collins is suggesting
is needed and i'm afraid it badly lets
down our children and young people
um it's going to bring in some extra
tutoring it's going to
bring in some training for teachers but
we know that
parents say that the most uh worrying
concern that they have following the
pandemic is their children's emotional
well-being their ability to
socialize with other children and and
their mental well-being so
it's a very limited announcement i'm
afraid that the government is making
and children and young people can't
really afford to wait for this
government
to get a sensible package that will
properly address
children's educational recovery and
their well-being
yes but in terms of of educational
recovery which
which presumably is most people's
priority here
um shouldn't that be the focus rather
than
um looking at the emotional state of
children i mean
i know not all but a lot of them do just
bounce back when things get back to
normal
so it's very clear that good learning
depends on good emotional and mental
well-being if you're worried if you're
frightened if you're withdrawn
and if you're not engaging with teachers
and other students then that is going to
inhibit your good learning and that's
why we say learning and wellbeing go
hand in hand and in fact
parents say and teachers say that it is
their top priority to address
children's mental well-being as a
prerequisite really for
good quality learning and for children's
happiness and their development
we also know very worryingly that and
kevin collins himself has identified
and arise in mental health problems
among children and young people
so this can't be an either or of course
we've got to help children recover lost
learning and it is worrying that
the gap entertainment between better off
children and more disadvantaged children
is widening and that has to be addressed
but
good quality mental health services and
social activities
the chance to play in development are
going to be equally important
and just not provided for in the
government's proposals yeah but 1.4
billion pounds announced today 1.7
billion pounds an ounce
at the end of last year i mean 3.1
billion in total
it's a lot of money
it's well short of what kevin collins
himself has said
is needed and of course the investment
we make in
children and young people today clearly
clearly crucially important for them but
it's also
really important for our country's
future success and prosperity
so we've seen um economic think tanks
like the institute for physical studies
suggesting that a
failure to um enable children to catch
up on lost learning and and recover from
the pandemic will cost hundreds of
billions of pounds to our
our country down the line so not making
this investment up front in children and
young people now
not only is that morally wrong we really
do have to prioritize our young people
it's also a false economy and i'm afraid
is the wrong choice
not to be prioritizing children's
learning and well-being
i mean the education secretary said this
morning they are prioritizing children
they're looking at increasing using this
money to increase one-on-one tuition
to catch up on lost learning to cover
six million students
their announcement today will actually
amount to an hour a fortnight of
tutoring for each pupil so i'm not sure
it's as bold and ambitious as the
education secretary
might like to suggest but as i've been
saying simply doing one element of what
needs to be a package of support and and
activity for children and young people
won't on its own be significant
sufficient yes
one-to-one tutoring and small group
tutoring is helpful it's good it can
really help children to make up lost
learning
but that will be inhibited we'll be
doing it with one hand behind our back
if we don't ensure that children's
well-being their social development is
attended to
and indeed if we don't ensure that
they've got enough to eat and are living
um in adequate material circumstances so
we're very concerned that yet again
um we will come to this summer's summer
holiday and children on free school
meals will receive
um free meals only for half the summer
holiday well children don't go on half
rations just because they're not in
school
and hungry children or children who come
back after the summer
not having eaten healthily are not going
to be able to learn well and develop
well
it's not enough just to say we're doing
the tutoring the government has to put
in place a whole package of support for
children and young people
especially the most disadvantaged and
its proposals today fall woefully short
of that
the education secretary does say though
that this is part of a process he
acknowledged that more needs to be done
he also said
you know that they were actively looking
at the idea of
of changing the school day so there was
perhaps more time
for learning would you support would the
labour party support
a longer school day
what we've been saying is that we could
use time now at the end of the school
day and indeed at the breakfast clubs
to offer a wider range of
extracurricular activities
sports music drama art you know schools
of fabulous
facilities and it's a shame for those
not to be being used uh after half past
three years or
in the holidays i i think if you ask
parents or teachers they will say you
know children get
tired you know the idea that you can
extend the school day
for lots of additional teaching of
academic subjects
and you get a really diminishing return
children won't learn well if they're
tired and if it's been a long school day
but i do absolutely want to see schools
being supported with the resources to
extend their facilities
beyond the end of the day for perhaps
local and
sports clubs youth groups to come in and
use those facilities
so that we can offer those broader
activities for children and young people
that are so crucial
for their social and emotional
development and indeed for their
learning
okay kate green thank you for your time
this morning
thank you